[Music]
just pH only have to do with solutions
in the laboratory or does it also affect
plants and humans in daily life did you
know that when acid rain flows into the
rivers the overall pH of the water
reduces and living organisms cannot
survive if the change in pH is too much
in such cases survival of aquatic
animals becomes difficult
what about survival of plants what's the
most important factor for the healthy
growth of a plant yes it's the soil
plants require a specific pH of the soil
for healthy growth plants cannot grow if
the soil is too alkaline or too acidic
so if the soil is too acidic its pH can
be raised by adding lye which
neutralizes the excess acid in the soil
similarly if the soil is too alkaline
then its pH can be lowered by adding
gypsum or some other substance which can
neutralize the excess alkali present in
the soil and does it affect us too by
now you should know that our stomach
produces hydrochloric acid which helps
in digestion
sometimes if too much acid is produced
it causes pain and irritation it can
even cause ulcers in order to treat this
hyper acidity a patient is advice to
take antacid tablets or antacid
suspensions and these antacids
neutralize the excess acid magnesium
hydroxide a mild base is often used for
this purpose and the reaction looks
something like this the acid is
neutralized to get salt and water what
about the pH in our mouth yes the pH in
our mouth also has an effect on our
teeth tooth enamel is the hardest
substance in our body and does not
dissolve in water and mildly acidic
solutions however it gets corroded
slowly when the pH in the mouth falls
below 5.5
but how does the pH fall below 5.5 when
we eat food some food particles remain
stuck to the teeth
bacteria present in the mouth produce
acid by the degradation of the sugar and
food particles present in the mouth this
is what causes decaying of the teeth
what's the best way to avoid this we
should clear our mouth after eating food
and something even better would be to
avoid eating sugary foods cleaning the
teeth using toothpastes help in
preventing tooth decay toothpastes are
generally basic and hence they
neutralize the excess acid in the mouth
and prevent tooth decay the concept of
pH also helps in understanding the
self-defense used by certain animals and
plants if you've ever been stung by a
honeybee do you know what really caused
that acute pain yes it's the acid in
that sting which caused the pain so if
we use a mild base like baking soda
around the stung area it gives us some
relief and in nature there are leaves
which have stinging hair and they inject
acid upon touching them again we use
something which is basic in nature to
get some relief so these were some of
the ways in which the concept of pH is
used in daily life in the coming videos
we will understand more about salts
[Music]